29 wage mich noch
[Musik]
maria theresien kaserne in wien erste
garde kompanie dann muss die tat war
natürlich schon gewissen das ziel haben
deswegen habe die jugend mitgebracht das
liegt mir die burschen auf herr
wachtmeister bitte das ist ein neuer
schöner tag bei der garde bitte kein
stress sagen wir einfach in zwei minuten
unten in voller montur
das thema jetzt mitten in der maria
theresien kaserne in wien gerade
kommando zweiten kommandanten beispiel
servicerobotern einen wunderschönen
guten morgen guten morgen was sind die
letzte aufgabe in der garde er zunächst
einmal sind wir verantwortlich für die
ausbildung von 1500 jungen soldatinnen
und soldaten ausbildung für den einsatz
sowohl für den repräsentations einsatz
wo es ja hinlänglich von der gerade
bekannt ist aber auch für alle anderen
einsatzrelevanten szenarien männer wie
frauen männer wie fragen über die jahre
hat auch noch andere aufgaben mit denen
sie über gesellschaftlich sind ja wir
unterstützen natürlich die
unterschiedlichsten karitativen
einrichtungen und haben im wahrsten
sinne des wortes sehr gute instrumente
dazu nämlich die gal mit musik deren
musikalischer botschafter ist und
darüber hinaus zb die aktion licht ins
dunkel
wo unsere soldaten am 24 dezember
telefonieren damit die aktion gut
unterstützen hoffentlich das produkt das
man erzeugt ist die repräsentation und
da ist jeder gleich wichtig egal woher
kommt was er für ein paar leben könnte
ich hier auch mitmachen
selbstverständlicher zuerst ist man noch
zum friseur gehen also mit reparatur
rasieren aber dann glauben wir das
hinbekommen also war der gar nicht unser
manchmal ist die einheitlichkeit
der oberste viel kind meldet der zigarre
kunden über mixa danke weitermachen und
dann den gefreiten raab übernehmen
jawohl gewährten gehabt übernehmen
ab
die retter müssen sich auf der strecke
[Musik]
das noch mal langsam
[Applaus]
einsteigen niederösterreich und hallo
und herzlich willkommen heißen da die
gerade nicht sein repräsentationsraum
band ist sondern auch ein fantastischer
verband hast du heute bei einem zug
stiessen dabei sein
okay das hört sich sehr wie in
touristische ausbildung aus nächster
nähe
genau hier ich keinen helm steht sie
weiß aber um und werben für dich hat
eine ganz spezielle aufgabe
ja und zwar ist der pokal des
sogenannten irgendwie treffens für eine
der wichtigsten aufgaben für so heißt
immer verbindung zum zug store anzuhören
ebene darf dabei helfen die schon da
zugs grand prix hinter der kritik für
auf schritt und tritt folgen
ok und wenn du bereit bist wir sind
bereit sein kann man loslegen dann gehen
wir bitten herstellen
[Musik]
herrlich
0 14 20 jahre meldung spitze
angeschossen kehre lage
[Musik]
es ist vom wähler
so und jetzt schauen wir das ganze mal
hinter nacht an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
egal ob präsentiert österreich tritt
nicht bei einsätzen im in- und im
ausland macht auf jedem exerzierplatz
einfach eine gute figur
sie habe nicht gewusst dass die auch
noch eine mit nicht perfekt ausgebildete
kampftruppe sind wir alles beherrscht
und das auf jedem teller
das habe ich heute selbst erfahren wir
ein bisschen außer atem das war ein
unglaublich was die burschen drauf haben
ein interessanter job und es war
wirklich toll zu sehen
egs laufen für bin fertig gute nacht
[Musik]